das hatte selbst fachleute verblüfft
völlig unerkannt kreis bereits seit drei
jahren einen mini mond um unsere erde
doch erst jetzt wurde der etwa auto
großen winzling entdeckt der der erde
etwa alle 47 tage umkreist hatte und
jetzt ist auch schon wieder weg kann er
uns trotzdem noch gefährlich werden
klicks und science fiction gibt's
wirklich spannendes science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen jetzt ist es
raus unser mond der die erde einmal in
27 tagen umkreist war mehrere jahre lang
nicht allein ein us astronomenteam hatte
einem zweiten himmelskörper entdeckt der
ebenfalls seine runden um die erde
drehte und das ist eine riesige
überraschung auch für das forschungsteam
selbst dazu der astronom caspar wird
schoss in einem interview mit dem
tagesspiegel kurz nachdem mein
teamkollege teddy prein und ich das
objekt entdeckt hatten haben wir den
orbit bestimmt und stellten fest dass es
von der erdanziehungskraft eingefangen
wurde
zu diesem zeitpunkt war es den
fachleuten allerdings nicht möglich das
objekt eindeutig zu identifizieren
handelt es sich etwa um ein natürliches
objekt oder aber um raumfahrt schrott
oder eben ein anderes künstliches objekt
nach angaben des minor planet center der
internationalen astronomischen union
gibt es mittlerweile aber bereits 50
beobachtung die die existenz von 2020 cd
drei bestätigten so steht nun auch fest
dass er die erde schon seit einiger zeit
begleitet hatte und zwar seit drei
jahren 2017 also ist er wohl in den
erdorbit gelangt und wurde seitdem von
ihrer schwerkraft eingefangen bis eben
jetzt das legen analysen des orbits nah
und bei dem mini mond handelt es sich um
einen echten winzling nach angaben der
fachleute ist er wohl einen asteroiden
zwischen 1 meter 90 und 3 meter fünfzig
groß ist somit entspricht seine größe
also in etwa der eines autos zum
vergleich unser echter mund hat einen
durchmesser von knapp 3500 kilometern
und noch ein entscheidender unterschied
den gibt es statt der gewohnten ellipse
die wir von unseren großen mond erkennen
lässt sich seine bisherige umlauf waren
eher mit dem stichwort chaos beschreiben
er kreist den etwa 2,6 einfacher mond
entfernung um die erde
dabei handelt es sich um ein weites oval
und dabei befand sich 2020 c3 meistens
außerhalb der umlaufbahn unsere
eigentlich mondes er benötigt die
berechnungen zufolge 47 tage um die erde
einmal so umkreisen selbst für die
fachwelt ist diese entdeckung eine große
sensation caspar features twittert von
zitat einer großen sache denn rund eine
million asteroiden sind uns bislang
bekannt und davon handelt es sich bei
2020 cd 3 um den zweiten der die erde
umkreist 2006 2007 hatte der us team
2620 die erde vier mal umkreist und sich
dann wieder entfernt und auch 2020 cd 3
hat uns jetzt ende märz verlassen da
seine umlaufbahn alles andere als stabil
war hat er sie jetzt verlassen eine
gefahr für die erde stellt der mini
brocken übrigens keinesfalls da
insgesamt sind es etwa 100000 bekannte
brocken die in der erdumlaufbahn um die
sonne kreisen und der erde nahe kommen
mit darunter sind welche die gigantisch
groß sind etwa so groß wie deutschland
aber auch welche die nur kieselstein
groß sind der leiter der hessischen
starkenburg sternwarte rainer kresken
sagt in einem interview mit der bild wir
beobachten diese brocken weil sie uns
gefährlich nahe kommen können bei einem
einschlag könnte ein großer ast eine
katastrophe auslösen 2020 cd 3 ist
allerdings zu klein klar ist aber auch
dass die erde mit ihrem einen mond ein
sonderling im sonnensystem ist außer
venus und merkur die gar keine trabanten
haben werden alle anderen planeten von
mehreren monaten umkreis bei jupiter
sind es beispielsweise 79 monde bei
saturn sogar 82 hat die erde einen
zweiten mond anklicken anschauen und
weltraum wissen von astor comics tv
unbedingt abonnieren cooler kanal bis
dann bleib dran